gentlemen how are you both doing we're
doing well steve how are you
listen i i cannot say enough great
things about this movie i'm sure you're
hearing that from everyone i loved this
film
so much um i i there's so many things to
talk about but um uh i'm curious when
you have been telling your friends and
family about this film what are the
things you keep going back to in terms
of what you're raving about to them the
things that you love about this movie
well i i personally i'm it's a i rave
about the needle nose
because working with him i i there's a
few directors in in my career that
where you
where you're incredibly happy and
incredibly creative on set where you
feel absolutely safe and you're you're
allowed to make mistakes and whatever
you try is allowed uh and uh
and
the atmosphere is is is friendly on the
set as well and that and denis
villeneuve is one of those very few
directors
and uh
working with him is such a pleasure that
i hope to be able to do it without a fat
suit someday
when i talk to people about the film and
specif specifically about the film
uh i focus on two things two things that
uh um
that really came to me when i was
watching the film and one
is that he really
denny really took
the characters and this world this
universe
um off the page and
put it there for us visually you know
now we have a visual reference to these
words
and the second thing
and i want to say that this i always say
that this is one of the most beautiful
films that i've ever seen in my life
and i'm you know
it's always
a risk to say this is the most beautiful
film because i feel like i might be
forgetting something there i don't want
to be disrespectful to anybody else
but this is probably the most beautiful
film that i've ever seen in my life
visually it's just it's just stunning
absolutely breathtaking
yeah the thing i
there's just no weak link in this movie
like everything is just so good it
doesn't make sense because it could have
gone off the rails in a million
different ways when you're dealing with
such complicated characters and
everything and i kind of want to touch
on that but the thing about dune is that
it brilliantly holds a mirror it might
be taking place in the future and on
another another planet but it
brilliantly takes this mirror to our
society and you know
the reflection can you sort of talk
about that aspect of the film if you
don't mind
i i you know i will touch on it briefly
um ellie um
stellen touched on it earlier and it's
much more eloquent than i could ever be
in my lifetime or in 10 lifetimes
but i think this really does it
it shows how
cruel people can be and
[Music]
in the search for power and you know and
the name of greed
i think we're absolutely experiencing
that you know across the world but
i you know i may be biased but i think
specifically in the united states it's
just become horrible you know what
people will do and what they will say
um
in the name of power and greed it's just
uh it's just sickening it makes me sick
it's heartbreaking to me which you know
you know you know steve i've
become very
politically involved and it's just an
uncomfortable place for me to be but i
feel like
you know it's my duty to to be a voice
of reason because i think there's just
so much injustice going on right now we
just the our country ours you know our
society
you know has digressed and
way too many ways it's it's really
it's it's it's hard for me like it's
really hard for me
i'm not sure if you wanted to add
anything stella
no i'm uh
of course it's uh it is it is uh
[Music]
what makes any piece of art uh
interesting to me is is is
i mean of course the aesthetics is
fantastic and all that but it but
aesthetics without a purpose are
meaningless
but it is about
human beings and it is about humanity
and even if it's uh
even if it's entertainment you feel it
and that that that enriches this film
enormously i think
thank you both for your time and dave
thank you for being active on twitter
with uh helping to raise awareness you
guys are fantastic in this thank you so
much for your time thank you stephen
thank you